but there's still
some amount of operations that will be
needed i would think over time how does
that get paid for you have
fees in a venture structure and those
fees trickle down to create a support
staff somebody can pick up the phone
somebody can do research uh on a tax
issue or a legal issue
um you know like if one of your projects
that you backed tried to screw you
how do you then
know that they're trying to screw you or
the or the lao
and or the flamingo and how do you take
legal action or you know who manages all
that in other words how is it staffed
yeah um so each one of the dows uh has
enlisted my my company attribute labs as
a service provider and we fill in a lot
of these gaps so we've handled
everything from the legal structuring to
the maintenance of the dap
to community support
we we kind of joke that we're like a mod
on a subreddit or a whip in congress
where we can help people focus their
activities or if a vote needs to be
taken
we can prepare certain information to
press that forward and then we handle
tax and compliance so all those
areas in between what you're describing
which is just the core decision making
that we want the members to do
and should be doing we we increasingly
take care of that um and we take a a two
percent uh annual fee there's some
variation on that depending on the doubt
but that's generally what we're uh what
we're focused on no carry which i think
is important because the members are
making their own decisions and we don't
have any investment related authority
it's all up to the members uh so we're
really like the support um we joke that
we're like uh we our dowser a little bit
like a reverse mullet and we handle um
the business all the business and
operations and
you guys have the party
yeah so the folks in the front can have
the party exactly so two percent of 70
million is 1.4 million uh so every year
that you run that you get 1.4 million
what do you do for that 1.4 million that
seems like a big number
yeah so
we provide uh the legal structuring so
we have the structure for the lao
flamingo neptune um
a digital fashion dial called red dao uh
we also have a
uh internet stable we've yes we've taken
our fake internet money to
build a fake internet stable um and we
also have a metaverse dial so there's
about uh nine dials right now uh that
was no but i'm saying what do you do for
that 1.4 million that seems like a big
number to me in venture the two
percent that you get as fees is for
sourcing the deals diligencing the deals
going on the boards and managing you
don't do that function so
it's a big number what do what do what
does the dow get for 1.4 million aside
from the legal structure
so they get the legal structuring they
also um get the
uh tooling uh so we're able to pull
together uh what we call adapt you could
view it like an online portal or
governance and other decision making can
occur uh we provide the community
support which does take a bit of work
you know just to keep people focused and
so those two things let's let's double
click on both those so in a way you're
like amazon web services or salesforce
like a sas provider of the management
software where the rules are written
where the votes are taken that is
actually super valuable
exactly and we've been building out
advanced dow tooling to make this all a
lot more efficient so right now you know
crypto is still early right we're
probably past the first inning but i
don't think we've seen the full ball
game yet uh there's a lot of work that
needs to be done on the dow side to
lower costs to increase operation but
what we've seen across the nine dows is
the types of problems that we think that
these online groups are going to face
and so since we see those problems we
can begin to solve them and then push
that down into a coherent tech stack so
you can view what we're supporting as a
broader network
instead of being a network of blogs or
network of uh different uh media
properties it's really a network of
these uh data-like structures uh or data
structures that all have the same or
similar legal structuring same tech
stack it's completely vertically
integrated so what you're learning in
flamingo might inform the lao might
inform the next one that makes total
sense and then
double clicking on the community
function you host that week those
bi-weekly calls um
you inform members send them email
updates of what's going on do you
prepare tax documents and statements for
them around all of us
so in a way you're like angelus carda or
shore which provides llc services for
folks
right
exactly so it's like that and then
there's areas in which our dials are
expanding uh so flamingo dial is a great
example it was really the first uh
substantive vehicle to explore nfts
collecting so it launched october of
last year as an example it's like the
number three holder of crypto punks uh
got in well before this upswing and that
was incubated by members of the lao so
through this hive mind this collection
of folks that we've assembled they saw
the nft opportunities i think before
most
traditional venture capital funds and
even um you know emerging crypto funds
and we're able to get in uh earlier than
that but that's expanding beyond even
kind of
things like collecting or supporting
projects they're beginning to work with
artists and
and doing drops in a more collaborative
way so there's additional technology and
tooling that's needed for it uh so lots
of these different functions we're able
to support uh as these these
organizations continue to grow they're
pretty organic in in terms of their
their general are they true
since you're doing them as a wrapped dow
uh
these wrapped dows are they
um
limited to accredited investors then
here in the united states because of the
accreditation laws
so yeah we we have uh the answer as to
whether they need to be is still an open
question uh so we've gone through kind
of a bifurcated analysis uh we're um you
know in the abundance of caution a
little bit like how i think circle
approaches things we want to take the
most conservative approach that we can
sound
to accredit investors and everybody goes
through a kyc and compliance
related check
and that's another reason why having a
service like tribute labs is important
right if uh there's a change in the
regulatory landscape if there's more
requirements that need to be handled
we'll be able to handle that and kind of
mutualize the cost across the entire
network which we think is important so
yes 99 members for now um and then
everybody is accredited uh but people
are you know stretched out across the
globe which i think is pretty pretty
interesting
so you're following the llc rules of 99
members
or 10 million cap with 250 i think is
the current llc structures for investing
in
startups
well there's a couple different
exceptions so we rely on kind of the 99
member instead of the 250 member 10
million dollar account yeah
um so that's a limitation how about the
open-endedness or the close-endedness of
this so
when you form the dow there's a period
in which people can join but the only
way to join after that is to buy
somebody else out is that correct
yeah it's either to purchase the
interest from somebody else or the
members have the ability to delete
themselves so what we've seen with the
lao and flamingo um the members have
decided to do that and they've let in
more folks so in the lab there's a 68
members in flamingo there's about 70
members and periodically they let in new
folks as part of that membership usually
at a higher price um oh wow so they can
command a higher price for them to join
in
which means they make a little profit on
new members joining
uh so they don't make a direct profit
but it kind of recreates their share
yeah the the unit the value of each unit
um right
in in the dow so as an example for
flamingo initially to join it was 60
ether for a hundred thousand units and
uh it looks like they're opening up new
membership and it's going to cost about
3 000 ether
for the same 100 000 units
got it and that would be to measure it
with
two things the exclusivity of it which
people can decide if they uh see value
in but also the portfolio i would think
has appreciated over some amount of time
because they're probably still holding
some eth and the nfts might have gone up
it's time for another r crowd deal of
the week right now you enjoying our
crowd's investment in intellect
according to the deal memo intellects
transportation innovation could save the
airline industry three billion dollars a
year intellect uses machine learning to
improve safety recognize hazards and
reduce delays and they're already being
used at some major international
airports and these airports serve over
100 million passengers annually
according to the deal memo we all know
that all over the world tech companies
are innovating and driving results for
investors well our crowd analyzes many
of these companies across the entire
global private market then they select
companies with the greatest growth
potential and bring them to you from
personalized medicine to cyber security
to robotics to quantum computing and
more in state-of-the-art labs startup
garages and anywhere in between our
crowd identifies innovators so you can
invest when the growth potential is
greatest and that's early so here's your
call to action if you're an accredited
investor you can join our crowd for free
at ourcrowd.com
twist and review the current deals there
is no payment involved until you decide
to invest that's rcrout.com twist to
sign up for free